stun performers are the unsung heroes of
Hollywood Productions and ahsokas are
some of the finest and the best so who
are the faces behind the fight
standing in is a stun double for a lead
protagonist is no easy job especially
when that protagonist is also a former
Jedi Rosario Dawson handles a majority
of Ahsoka scenes in the series including
a lot of the action but she doesn't do
it all that's where Michelle C Lee comes
in though Lee is an immensely skilled
martial artist and stun woman she's also
a talented actor in her own right you
may know her from her role as Oxana in
2021's black widow or as Violet in the
Paramount plus Avengers series blood and
treasure Lee's stun credits are
extensive including everything from top
gun Maverick to Suicide Squad to Pacific
Rim beyond the film and television liais
also contributed her skills as a motion
capture artist for a number of Major
Video Games those credits include
Uncharted the Lost Legacy The Last of Us
left behind and most notably the Mortal
Kombat series Lee has worked extensively
in the latter franchise even playing
Molina in the 2013 web series Mortal
Kombat legacy perhaps it's no surprise
then that she was chose chosen to take
on such an important and intensive role
drawing production on Ahsoka
Sabine ran as a unique fighting style to
say the least she is trained on the Jedi
such as Kanan Jairus and Ahsoka Tano as
well as mandalorians and even
instructors at the Imperial Academy as a
result her approaching combat is
something of a mishmash equal parts
Rebel Bounty Hunter Mandalorian warrior
and Jedi Knight take us out
does take a lot of the work in bringing
that unique fighting style to life she
has some help too Ahsoka episode 7
credits Xiao naomova as a stunt double a
younger performer who still seems to be
making a name for herself in Hollywood
though she isn't marked as a stunt
performer for the show on IMDb now
mover's page does also credit her as
playing the role of Lieutenant jensu one
of the X-Wing pilots who accompanies
General Harris in Doula to sitos that
particular Squadron is apparently full
of stunt performers as long time din
jarin stand in Brendan Wayne also flies
a fighter in the same scene apart from
Ahsoka narumova's only credit on IMDb is
for playing the Street Fighter character
Ibuki in a low budget TV series
according to weistern naomova was also a
competitor on season 4 of NBC's World of
Dance hopefully her multiple roles in
Ahsoka will help to elevate her profile
and career in the years to come
for a villain with a poison presence of
Ray Stevenson's Balin skull you need a
stunt double equal to the task and
that's exactly what the Ahsoka crew
found and they hired Morgan Benoit you
may not know benoit's name but you've
almost surely seen his work he was a
stun double for Keanu Reeves in 2013's
47 Ronin and he has Stone credits on
major action films like Terminator dark
fate Renfield and dune all of those
credits should have been enough to get
Benoit the role of Stevenson's stuntable
on Ahsoka but it probably didn't hurt
that he also had experience in the Star
Wars Universe he has performed stun work
on the Mandalorian since 2020 and he
even lent his talents at a big budget
video game Star Wars Jedi Survivor
earlier in 2023 in short he was the
perfect man for the job and Valence
goals intense aggressive lightsaber
fights stand his Testament to that fact
having worked on the Mandalorian
probably wasn't a requirement for stun
performance to get hired on Ahsoka but
it clearly wasn't a mark against them
Morgan Benoit wasn't the only performer
to move from one Star Wars show to the
other Alicia Villa Bailey the
Thunderball for Ivano sagnos character
hearty did as well in addition to her
previous Star Wars work valer Bailey has
earned credits as gal gadot's done
double for Wonder Woman and Batman v
Superman dawn of Justice she also played
at them aspirin Warrior early on in the
first Wonder Woman movie Star Wars isn't
the only Disney franchise that fella
Bailey has experienced in either she's a
true veteran of the Marvel Universe
appearing in several of the Netflix
shows including the Punisher and the
Defenders as well as Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 and agents of shihon in
which he played the role of Alicia
Whitley Vela Bailey has lent her talents
to the Avatar franchise as well playing
a member of the villainous recom unit in
avatar The Way of water on that
production she also worked as a stun
double for both sigoni Weaver and Zoe
Saldana
fans of Star Wars Rebels are more than
elated at the end of Ahsoka episode 6
when Iman is foundy's Ezra Bridger
finally made his on-screen debut the
character is instantly recognizable as a
beloved Jedi robe from the animated
series and has found he captures Ezra
spirits and personality perfectly
force is my Ally that's all I need it
was even more exciting for fans to see
Ezra leap into action in ahsoka's
seventh episode in which esfandi was
assisted by his stuntable Jason Chu once
again we've got a Mandalorian alumnus
here she has also worked on Disney
projects such as agents of shield and
Captain America Civil War as well as
multiple entries in the modern planets
of the apes franchise he's been
particularly busy over the past several
years lending his skills to movies such
as Army of the Dead Blade Runner 2049
and free guy among other projects one
thing's for sure he's not inexperienced
Ezra's 4-centric fighting style in
Ahsoka is a lot of fun to watch and if
their social media activity is any
indication Chu and his fandi forced a
strong bond during production the actor
was commenting on his stunt doubles
Instagram posts as recently as December
2022 pumping him up over some snazzy
bits but you'd expect nothing less from
the as Ruby will know and love wouldn't
you
[Music]
foreign